- Florence Noël, 79 ans, connaît
les camions. Elle en conduit
depuis près de 60 ans.
FLORENCE NOËL, camionneuse
- Ça fait ma 57e année
sur les dix roues, mais avant,
j'ai fait de la charrue à neige
aussi. On avait des contrats
en déneigement avec la
municipalité.
- Chaque jour de la semaine,
elle transporte du gravier, du
concassé, du sable, de la terre,
et aujourd'hui, de l'asphalte.
Elle est en forme.
- Jamais de problèmes.
Je suis en santé, je ne prends
pas de pilules encore.
D'habitude, je touche à du bois
quand je dis ça pour pas que ça
arrête, là. Non, je suis en
parfaite santé. Je suis
chanceuse. Regarde Philippe!
C'est ma première petite tomate.
- Philippe est son jeune frère
de 74 ans. Il est aussi
camionneur. Il est très fier de
sa grande soeur et heureux de
travailler souvent avec elle.
PHILIPPE ROY, frère de Florence
- Elle est parfaite sur un
camion. Elle peut...
Bien des fois, des hommes sont
pas capables de faire ce qu'elle
peut faire, la petite soeur.
Elle estadroite avec
un camion. Elle a toujours été
de même.
- Aînée d'une famille
de 19 enfants, Florence
a toujours travaillé dur.
- Je suis une petite fille de
cultivateur, puis on travaillait
fort sur une ferme. On trayait
des vaches avant d'aller à
l'école. On "runnait" des
tracteurs. J'allais mener les
bidons de crème, j'avais 7 ans.
Je faisais à peu près troismiler
aller porter la crème avec ma
soeur, puis on se mettait les
deux après le bidon de lait....
- Connue de tous les camionneurs
de la région de Magog, elle est
respectée de tous.
FRANCIS BOILY
- Moi, je dirais qu'elle est
très travaillante. Elle peut
en faire. Elle n'arrête pas.
Elle n'arrête pas. Elle peut...
Le samedi, s'ils v
demander de travailler,
elle va y aller. Elle va y
aller le dimanche aussi.
Les soirs, elle dit qu'elle a
plein d'plein d'plein d'plein di
à la maison, les fleurs,
les plates-bandes.
- Les gars sont bien gentils.
Je leur dis : vous me devez
respect, je suis la plus
vieille de toute vous autres.
C'est vrai que dans mon
association des camionneurs,
je suis la plus vieille
de toute la gang.
- Le camion qu'elle conduit
est usagé. Plus jeune,
elle en aurait acheté un neuf.
- Usagé, c'est pas toujours
le fun parce que des fois,
tu t'attends qu'il va être
meilleur que ça, puis tu mets
de l'argent dedans.
- Elle adore toujours son mé
et veut le faire encore pendant
quelques années.
- À moins de gagner à la
lotterie, ça, c'est sûr que
j'arrête.
- Florence Noël est la preuve
que la passion du travail
n'a pas d'âge.
Ici Jean Arel,
Radio-Canada